on le sait les antennes relais
installées pour les téléphones portables
émettent des ondes radioélectriques
alors dangereuses ou pas à brest la
municipalité a décidé de mesurer les
niveaux d'ondés en fonction des
quartiers de la ville et en temps réel
il s'agit de lever les inquiétudes des
habitants et notamment des riverains et
christophe clément gabriel cabine ya sur
place
donc voici un boîtier de mesure de notre
système qui est située à une trentaine
de mètres d'une antenne de téléphonie
mobile à la mairie de brest on n'est pas
peu fier de cette innovation
technologique développée par deux
start-up local est utilisée à deux
endroits de la ville il mesure en temps
réel les ondes émises par les
différentes antennes et les retransmet
sur un site internet celui de la
communauté urbaine un site internet sur
lequel les brestois peuvent consulter
chaque jour les mesures d'ondés
électromagnétiques émises par les
antennes relais des opérateurs portable
un dispositif qui vise à rassurer les
habitants s'aperçoit que les ondes eux
sont de 1,5 volt par mètre à quelques
dizaines de mètres soit moins connus de
vote de la charte de paris et je crois
que c'est important pour une
collectivité locale de donner
l'information aux habitants avec le
développement du téléphone portable les
implantations d'antennes relais se
multiplient près de 100 autour de brest
et certains habitants s'inquiètent des
conséquences pour leur santé
je pense que les gens ont besoin de
savoir effectivement si la santé mise en
jeu et si et connaître des chiffres
je trouve ça tout à fait normal c'est
pas prouver quelque chose d'aussi toi j
bien mais effectivement c'est peut-être
une prévention
samuel pas chaque jour environ 300
personnes consultent le site
le système financé à moitié par la
communauté urbaine et par les deux
société brestoise a coûté 39 milles
euros
une première en france qui pourrait
intéresser d'autres grandes villes